the Asian values debate unfortunately is
the most missed titles that most badly
miss title the way in the world because
the Asian values debate came about at
the end of the Cold War because there
was an Asian reaction to Western
triumphalism I mean I was there I went
to Europe I went to America and I was I
mean the Western intellectuals were just
plain cocky they their attitude to us
the rest of the world was hey the Cold
War's ended the West has won now you the
rest of the world you have only one road
of history you all have to become
cultural clones of the West and that's
what the Asians rejected they said no we
will not become cultural or political
clones of the West and it was that
reaction that was named the Asian values
debate is not that the Asians disagree
about about the values of democracy over
the values of human rights why we
disagreed about the way the West said it
should be implemented and history by the
way has vindicated what the Asian said
because the societies that tried to go
overnight think Yugoslavia it was a
disaster thousands of people died
because of this experiment and democracy
that was imposed and Yugoslavia take
Rwanda 800,000 people died because you
tried to convert it democracy without
paying attention to the underlying
ethnic fabric down there
these things you got to change carefully
and in that sense the Asian approach or
say hey let's do these things carefully
and deliberately and that has I think
been vindicated and now of course as you
know
no no Westerner advocates the immediate
democracy is the way that they used to
in 1990 1995
you